well if his appearances in the police
academy films are any indication this
next young actor doesn't count his lines
when he looks at a script he counts how
many noises he gets to make
it's hard to imagine a better choice to
present the oscar for sound effect
editing
than michael winslow
the job of sound effects editor is to
match the sound effect with the picture
like a helicopter firing a rocket
they're giving out awards for sound
effects how about this
hey hey we got a winner up here
now being a sound effects editor is to
well it's a fun job because they have
all these great sound effects to work
with
for example a sports car crashing into
an ice cream stand
let's see that again no not no time
tonight the nominees for achievement in
sound effects editing are
charles l campbell and robert rutledge
for back to the future
bob henderson and alan murray for lady
hawk
frederick j brown for rambo first blood
part two
and the winner is drum roll please
the winner is oh charles l campbell and
robert
back to the future
i first dreamed of this great honor
a long time ago a long way from
hollywood
on a front porch swing ladies and
gentlemen of the academy i
am most deeply grateful and for all of
you out there
who harbor such dreams as i
may your time come too thank
okay you thank you i'd like to thank the
academy very much
and i'd like to dedicate this to my late
mother editor
evelyn rutledge for the 48 years she put
in this business thank you
you